Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today, Congressman Ro Khanna, who
represents California's 17th District.
Congressman, you know, I have to say, over
the last three months, there has sort of been
new life breathed into the Biden administration
and Joe Biden, a number of legislative accomplishments.
He seems significantly more energetic, arguably
one of the most productive COVID isolation
periods of anyone I can think of.
Joe Biden had a couple of months ago.
Do you get the sense that this will impact
November's midterms for Democrats in the House
like you, or that these are really siloed
accomplishments that that the Biden administration
is experiencing?
Speaker 4: There is a sense of momentum, and
that's because Democrats are delivering.
The president delivered student debt relief.
We're bringing manufacturing back to America
with the semiconductor bill that I led with
chips and science.
We are have the largest investment in climate
in American history.
So there's a sense that what the president
said he would do, what we said we would do
in 2020, we are doing.
And that is finally breaking through.
And there's also a sense that the Democratic
Party is more unified than we've been probably
since the beginning of the president's term.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that that seems absolutely
to be taking place.
And when you particularly contrast to what's
happening in the Republican Party, where the
RNC is stopping paying Trump's legal bills,
and you're seeing significant disagreements
on what the 2024 Republican nomination should
look like and whether the presence of people
like Liz Cheney is even remotely welcome.
It does seem like there is significantly more
unification among the Democratic Party.
And also on some issues there seems to be
disagreement.
I mean, the student loan debt relief is an
example where you have some who believe, even
on the Democratic side, there should be no
such debt relief at all.
People decided to take out these loans and
they should pay the loans.
On the other hand, individuals who say all
student loan debt should be forgiven and then
folks kind of in the middle who say, well,
some some debt relief is a good idea.
Where are you on further debt relief?
Speaker 4: I'm for getting debt relief up
to 50,000.
I mean, the reality is $10,000 is often what
it costs someone to do one semester at a college
or one year at a community college.
It's not enough.
But I applaud the president for taking a major
step.
This is going to help a lot of working and
middle class folks.
It is, again, a precedent for doing more.
So I want to applaud him but say that the
job is not done.
Speaker 1: On the manufacturing jobs.
Explain to us exactly how one brings the job
back to the United States from overseas, where
that will increase the total cost to produce
whatever is being produced without making
inflation worse.
Like, what's the economic sequence wherein
we can do that?
Speaker 4: Actually producing more things
in the United States could help a long term
with inflation.
I mean, one of the reasons we had inflation
is we didn't make masks here.
We didn't make semiconductors there.
So you had to ship them from overseas at $15,000
shipping per container as opposed to $2,000.
And the fact that we didn't have enough production
meant that we had too much money chasing too
few goods.
If you increase production long term, that
is deflationary.
But you're saying in a micro case, well, how
are you going to produce it here when wages
may be higher, when environmental standards
may be higher?
I think that's why you need both government
collaboration in terms of financing.
I mean, other countries have helped finance
new factories, new industries, government
support on the workforce, development at community
colleges, and a collective regional economic
development effort.
That's what we did with FDR to build our economy.
And there's no reason we can't do it now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I guess the shipping
is is certainly a factor, but 15,000 versus
two for a shipping container paying dramatically
lower wages on every unit on an ongoing basis
seems like it would be it would override the
shipping cost.
I mean, I guess it depends on the product
and we'd have to sort of look at the details.
But it seems also there probably has to be
some shift in the thinking from the American
public about the advantages to domestic manufacturing
as well.
And I don't know that the messaging is really
there on that.
Speaker 4: Well, I'm not sure it requires
a change in consumer behavior.
Obviously, it'd be great to buy American,
but you could have government purchasing American
with all the purchasing power we have that
make a difference.
Second, a lot of the advanced manufacturing
has much less labor costs.
Because of automation, it has increased productivity.
Now people say, well, this means less jobs,
which is true, but those are going to be higher
paying jobs and it's going to mean more competitiveness
for the product.
So I think when it comes to it against manufacturing
interval, interval with textiles, for example,
as opposed to traditional manufacturing, that
can be done here and will be done here.
And the quality is often higher here.
That's not just an opinion.
The productivity of American workers is more
than Germany or Japan.
And so I think we have to be very deliberate
about the type of production that can be done.
The government partnership that is required.
And we can do it in a way that is cost competitive.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
You know, one one high tech product that is
being manufactured at least partially in the
United States is Tesla electric vehicles.
And it's been very interesting to see that
many on the right.
You would think, as I outlined yesterday,
they should love electric vehicles.
You can charge them at home with solar panels
you own and not be.
Right.
There's the self-sufficiency aspect to it.
For people who like fast cars, which are associated
with alpha males in some right wing circles,
electric vehicles are very fast.
There's all these reasons why the right should
really be embracing electric vehicles, and
yet they seem almost angry about them to some
degree.
Your colleague Marjorie Taylor GREENE and
many others are furious about electric vehicles.
Are you surprised by the antipathy towards
them from some on the right?
Speaker 4: I'm not because that's horseshit.
Climate has become so politicized that anything
that is almost good for the climate generates
skepticism on the right.
And that's why I think we could just talk
about the new industrialization of America.
Let's build the new industries, new factories
here.
It turns out a lot of that will be clean and
a lot of that is going to be clean steel,
new batteries, new electric vehicles, new
charging station, hydrogen jets, hydrogen
planes.
We can talk about building new factories,
new industry, new manufacturing.
And that may cut across the the the political
divide.
Speaker 1: On on cannabis decriminalization.
You and I have spoken about this before.
My sense has been it's never been a particularly
interesting topic for President Joe Biden.
But at the same time, I didn't think he was
going to do any student loan debt relief.
And I was very, very much wrong there.
Do you get any sense that there may be something
before November on cannabis from the Oval
Office?
Speaker 4: I don't you know, I obviously have
not just for decriminalizing it, I'm taking
for taking it off Schedule C, for legalizing
marijuana.
But I think this is something that's personal
for the president.
My understanding is that he has had people
with substance abuse in his own family, that
that is informing his view.
It's obviously a view that I disagree with,
but because it's something that seems to be
a sincerely held conviction on his part, one
that I disagree with, I'm not sure that we're
going to see movement on that.
Speaker 1: Do you do you expect that in the
long term, the cannabis issue is going to
be dealt with more at the state level as it
has been so far, or that at some point there
will be a federal change?
Speaker 4: I think it's going to start at
the state level.
But my sense is within the next couple cycles,
presidential cycles, there'll be a federal
change because you have people on the Republican
side, the the younger generation that understands
the importance of legalizing cannabis and
the medical uses and the fact that cannabis
often is less dangerous, certainly less dangerous
than the opioids, and yet more restrictive
than some of the opioids.
Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit about the
upcoming midterms.
So if we want to take just one forecast, the
FiveThirtyEight forecast says it's roughly
a 2 to 1 chance that Democrats hold the Senate.
And by a roughly 4 to 1 margin, Democrats
are likely to lose the House.
Now, on the House, some of the recent momentum
you mentioned is not really in those numbers
quite yet, but it's a pretty significant hill
to climb at this point.
And sort of the most mathematically likely
outcome is a divided Congress.
It seems to me that this will be two years
of total Republican obstruction to prevent
any major legislation and then using the lack
of accomplishments that they cause as justification
to vote for a Republican president in 2024.
That seems to be what the game plan is going
to be.
Are you and your colleagues talking about
that as the most likely outcome and what what
can be done, if anything?
Speaker 4: But we're still hopeful that we
can hold the house, especially after New York
19.
And the surprising result there that Ryan
wasn't expected to win.
He really ran an abortion rate.
We're seeing, as, you know, increased registration
among young women, in particular in Ohio,
in Pennsylvania.
So are we underdogs to hold the house?
Yes, of course.
The president's party always loses seats.
We're in a tough economic climate, but we're
still focused on how we do that.
And the argument that we're making to it to
be able to do that is where is the Republican
agenda?
I mean, we have an agenda.
I can tell you what we will do on inflation.
We're going to try to get childcare done.
We're going to make sure that we are providing
greater benefits for for Medicare.
We're going to increase Social Security.
We're going to produce more things in America.
The Republicans have no agenda.
They're basically just running anti Biden.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's basically just obstruct.
There's no doubt about that.
But nonetheless, if they successfully do that
for two years, it's not a super strong argument
for Democrats to say, well, yes, we got nothing
done, but it wasn't our fault.
I mean, it just it doesn't sound like the
type of thing that voters will buy.
So what do you do if that does end up being
the situation?
Speaker 4: Well, it depends.
I mean, obviously, President Obama and President
Clinton had obstructionist Republican Congresses
and both won reelection.
And they did it by showing just how extreme
the Republican Congresses work.
Right.
So it depends on whether the Republicans overplayed
their hand, which they're very capable of
doing.
I mean, if all they're doing when they take
power is try to impeach Joe Biden and do hearings
on Hunter Biden and all the other conspiracy
theories, then I think the American public
will tire of that and say we need more reasonable
people.
I in the past, but they've had the majority.
They have overreach.
So there's no reason to think they wouldn't
do that again.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that laptop from hell is
really something.
Congressman, we've got it.
We've got to look at that hard drive, especially.
Last thing I want to ask about.
How much in the among your colleagues is there
discussion of the Mar a Lago search warrant
and just the, you know, 60 truth social posts
a day from the former president?
Like something is very, very wrong over there.
How much does that play in the day to day
between you and your colleagues and sort of
considering that side of what's taking place
in as you think about your 2022 campaign and
then moving beyond 22?
Or is it wholly irrelevant to what you and
your colleagues are doing?
Speaker 4: But we've tried not to talk about
it that much because it's a law enforcement
matter and we've actually tried not to politicize
it.
The last thing you want is every Democratic
member of Congress going on CNN or your podcast
giving an opinion on what the Justice Department
should do.
Right.
That said, what does come up are the threats,
frankly, that colleagues are facing in this
environment.
And they're more than I've ever seen in six
years.
You had Eric Swalwell post yesterday about
the threat he received.
One of his staffers received really ugly things.
And unfortunately, I'm hearing that kind of
threats and violence much more from colleagues,
which is concerning.
Speaker 1: Are there I mean, obviously, I
don't want you to share what's being done,
but is there a different or more involved
sort of security apparatus that is that is
now involved because of this?
Speaker 4: There is, but you can't protect
in an open democracy, everyone from a culture
of violence.
I mean, look, members of Congress, we are
in parades.
I was just in the pride parade in San Jose.
We are we do town halls with hundreds of people.
We sit in coffee shops.
And that's how it's supposed to be.
And for many, many decades, people did that
to both parties without really worrying about
political violence.
I mean, obviously, you had crazy shootings
and mass shootings, but those were one off
incidents.
Now you're at a point where there are members
of Congress, unfortunately, who will be advised
to sit out a town hall or a parade or a community
event.
And this is one of the real damages that doesn't
get talked about enough in our democracy that
the right is causing, which is this fear of
being connected to people.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And sadly, the sort of a growing belief among
some that violence is an acceptable way to
try to achieve political change or to make
your opinions known, which is really scary.
And that goes to the gun culture aspect as
well.
Right?
Seeing guns as a legitimate tool to solve
interpersonal problems.
Speaker 4: You know, when I was growing up,
the one thing almost a cliché was, well,
in America, we solve our political problems
without violence.
Right.
Transfer of power.
I mean, everyone would say that is a sort
of pointing to why we're the greatest democracy.
And it's sad to me that something that basic
is now being being questioned.
Fortunately, we still are in a relatively
peaceful place and these are threats and they
haven't become full for a full board assassination
attempts.
But in other countries, you know, you literally
have political parties trying to assassinate
each other.
And we've got to be very careful that we don't
cross into a line where violence becomes condoned
as part of the political culture.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we don't want to we don't
want to end up there.
And Lindsey Graham earlier this week getting
dangerously close to that.
But we'll we'll leave that for for another
conversation.
We've been speaking with Democratic Congressman
Ro Khanna, who represents California's 17th
District.
Always a pleasure having you on.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
Really appreciate it.